So could you firstly define the term
Ramadan?
Alhamdulillah. The word Ramadan is
derived from the Arabic word Ramida or
Ramad which means intense scorching heat
and dryness. It's also derived from the
Arabic word
ramda which means sunbaked sand. In
Islamic terminology, the word Ramadan,
it signifies the intense heat in the
stomach due to
thirst. When a Muslim fasts, the thirst
that is there, it produces heat in the
stomach which is defined as
Ramadan. Again,
Ramadan, it has another meaning. It
means that the good deeds they scorch
the sins and the evil of a Muslim. So
Ramadan is a month in which the sins are
scorched away by the good deeds like how
a sun scorches the ground in the same
way.
And heat normally it helps in forming,
molding or
reshaping virtually every matter. In the
same way Ramadan helps in molding,
shaping and reforming the spiritual and
the moral aspects of the human being.
That's the reason we term this word as
from